salut et bienvenue sur ce casse-tête de
la loupe qui boxe cast est bien prise de
tête selon les retours que j'ai eu des
personnes qui possèdent la loupe ebook
[Musique]
de quoi voir tu veux m'en sortir
c'est une bonne reprise pourquoi le mot
reprises
parce qu'en réalité nous sommes le 24
août et nous on rentre juste de vacances
a fait deux mois que j'ai pas fait de
castets et je recommence avec un 5 sur 6
5 sur 6 donc 18 experts mais celui-là il
nous a été recommandé par l'un c'est
l'autre casse-tête si vous cherchez un
endroit où acheter des bons casse-tête
en france et l'insoluble je vous mets un
lien dans la description bref là on se
fait la lupi boxe c'est reparti pour des
tournages de milan ils auront lieur ils
chassent des quartiers comme geagea il
fut la brasse comme personne non plus
mais il est là pour casser des casse
tête et ça va faire mal c'est fabien
mediastay on est parti pour un petit
monde va ensemble avant de commencer je
vous le dis cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par north vpn normes epn numéro un
mondial avec 14 millions d'utilisateurs
sûrement le vpn le plus rapide du marché
qui fonctionne sur les principales
plateformes françaises eyeos windows
macos il ya même linux même l'android tv
elle fonctionne avec l'application nord
vdn directement dessus je vous en
reparle dans la vidéo mais sachez
qu'avec le lien qui rend la description
et mon code fabien olicard vous avez une
grosse réduction sur un abonnement de
deux ans et un cadeau en bonis ce jeu
vous fait voir un peu de casse tête ici
ab je vous fais voir ce côté là il ya
plusieurs niveaux en fait tout ça s'est
creusée vous le voyez il n'y a rien qui
bouge on voit que c'est une seule et
même pièce ça ça ne se tire pas ce côté
là il ya la kz je pense de la boîte qui
doit s'ouvrir comme ça on verra tout à
l'heure là c'est juste les pièces qui ce
qu'ils se remettent la ici nous avons
une boule qui est aimanté et qui vient
ici se positionner en tout cas d'origine
à les positionner là dessus et là bas on
a la même phase dans l'autre sens
la boule elle va là aussi elle va là
aussi en dessous rien de spécial en
groupe tout ce qui nous intéresse c'est
ça on voit ici lac de rotation sauf si
c'est un piège c'est ça et on voit donc
que la boîte est elle veut s'ouvrir
comme ça même si on cherche on voit que
ça bouge pas si mal là on a un cadran
numérotées de 1 à 7 700 chiffre magique
sa planche à neige et les sept nains les
sept merveilles du monde les sept péchés
capitaux les sept mers tout près tu m'as
compris ici en un petit pitou youla que
je peux saisir
vous le verrez pas très bien mais ça on
peut le tirer ça reste pas forcément en
position lacan quand ça quand le pay to
you say is war est enfoncé on ne peut
pas le tourner mais quand on tire dessus
on peut tourner le cadran et du coup la
corde qui passe pour ouais on peut
revenir en arrière oui ok ici on a la
boîte et là on est un petit trou et
qu'en tire sur la corde on sent bien que
la corde là cela par vous dire je vois
trop de preuves de ce que j'avance mais
on sent bien qu'elle ait complètement
l'achat n'est pas retenu par quoi que ce
soit dans un guide donc ici doit y avoir
un axe et lie à la corde qui passe
autour de cet axe est donc pour ouvrir
il faut faire quoi il faut pouvoir
enlever la corde donc soit par ce côté
là deux côtés de la bouche de menthe et
ce qui me paraît enfin vous en
conviendrez avec moi assez impossible
puisque ici je vois la colle
qui retient la corde dans la boule et
qui resserrait ici par ce petit aimant
on a sept cordes on a ça et puis ici
donc on axe comme ça peut-être à week du
coup quand je fais ça ça avait enroulé
la corde même si ça va être par
l'intérieur ça va être un all apache est
tendue ça va être un système en fait de
en roulage déroulage de la corde je
pense pour pour qu'elles pour qu'on la
fasse quitté lax les cordes c'est hyper
brainfuck c'est à dire que des fois on
peut défaire un noeud qui emprisonne
quelque chose malgré le fait qu'ils
aient quelque chose je pense que là ça
doit être à peu près le même bail
[Musique]
je pense que la théorie c'est que c'est
facile à comprendre et que c'est très
chiant à faire je pense que c'est ça je
vais quand même exploré tous éléments
parce que c'est pas les règles d'un
casse est une bonne exploration vaut
mieux que je vais chercher comme comme
j'allais dire un gros comme un mec bête
en fait pendant des heures pour
découvrir quelque chose après la
deuxième règle des casse tête c'est un
casse tête n'est vraiment résolu que
quand il est refait à la fin troisième
règle de des casse-têtes sa difficulté
n'est pas déterminée par le prix
financier la valeur du casse-tête et 4e
règle les difficultés des casse têtes
sont régies par le grand centre d des
gens qui se conservent pour dire si les
dureront pas dur à priori à rien de
tisser menthe et je me dis si je tourne
le cadran c'est à dire que cette cette
corde là elle va être prise aussi à
l'intérieur et elle va sans rouler en
plus en faisant un petit coup de comm sa
donc je vais avoir un côté avec une
corde qui fait le tour entier et un
autre truc de la corde en plus
donc si je continue à tourner dans la
spirale ça ne se défera pas si je le
passe ici l intérieur par au dessus ce
que je pourrais faire sortir c'est pas
se prendre sous sa clac clac clac clac
et je faisais retourner non va pas
recréer un noeud je ferai pas plus si je
passe un bout de corde par la genre lui
que je fais un tour entier
[Musique]
ah mais c'est impossible la théorie
c'est que je prenne la corde que je la
passe non pas par le haut comme ça mais
par le dessous celle ci comme ça après
je tourne dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre et comme ça que c'est elle
est séparée là là et quand elle revient
là en fait ça a défait le tour et je
ressors tout part en dessous et je
devrais pouvoir tirer quand j'ai envie
de faire un essai avec de la vraie
cordes et essayons avec un câble de
manette voir ce que c'était là ici il ya
un axe on va dire que l' axe ses seize
davis au poids voilà parfait votre
honneur ok un bout de corde comme ça
et que je le rentre dans le trou titre
il va y avoir des titres il ya un trou
un trou égale des titres on sait donc
que je le rentre comme ça non là dedans
comme ça voilà ça donnerait ça et que ça
je le tourne donc que j'arrive à faire
non d'ailleurs il faudrait que je le
tourne comme ça en entier et faudrait
que je le tourne de la gauche vers la
droite ça ferait bien ça et ça la
théorie est validé donc si je rentre lui
il faudrait que je tourne
dans le sens inverse de ce que pense
[Musique]
non ça marche pas
y'a pas des mandants la corde si elle se
trouve il ya un élément de l'accord
était de le récupérer reste que je veux
dire qu'il est que constantin est caché
un petit bout des mois dans la corde qui
fait que quand tu mets ça
fonctionne pour
nadja russie et le trou est live ici
elle fait ça comme ça sur les côtés si
je pousse comme ça avant elle est censée
remonter ici les côtés par contre qu'ils
ont et je la rendent un peu plus sur le
côté pour que ça puisse potentiellement
se lever un peu et que je puisse pas à
se lever un peu pour que ça se lève bien
coin
là j'ai fait vous voyez pas mais j'ai
fait trois lignes en fait j'ai la ligne
de suite droite la ligue 2 suite gauche
j'essaie de faire en sorte que ça écrase
les deux et entre les deux dents pacéen
et et qu'en appuyant il se relève en
fait qu'ils seraient le fait pas monter
un seul millimètre dans la boîte ça n'a
pas fonctionné
voir dans ce sens là si j'essayais de
faire juste l'un des rares déjà pour
vous faire voir la difficulté le placer
d'ici à là dedans c'est déjà une galère
mais ça ça fonctionne je peux le passé
par l'intérieur quand même c'est que si
je le passe par l'intérieur a clashé un
tour je ne met pas et est ce que comme
ça je peux m'aider à le placer dans
l'autre sens à tanger fléchi peut-être
on attend qu'ils ont peut-être un truc
si je fais ça et ça peut-être qu'en
tirant comme ça en gros [ __ ] c'est
trop bien en gros ça le faire passer à
l'intérieur du trou c'était possible ça
me fait une boucle et je me dis un peu
comme quand on fait de l'électricité je
sais pas si vous avez déjà fait
l'électricité ou quad en maudit quand il
passe une gaine après tu fais comment
pour attirer ton fils dans la gaine et
donc tu peux laisser en fait un fils
dedans pour cette gaine qui servira plus
tard comme ça après tu mets ton fils
électriques il accroche au fils tu tire
le fil et l'autre fils arrive et je me
dis il ya peut-être moyen de faire la
même chose d'ailleurs cette boucle là
que j'ai passés par eau si j'arrive à
lui attacher une boucle du bas et que
j'arrive à ramener après l'ensemble
comme ça puis part en eau ce serait se
serait ou chambres et [ __ ] ça ça
marche pas parce que la maintenance et
roulait trop petit ça fait un noeud
c'est qu'on paie cela il ya un truc à
faire avec ça quand j'ai envie d'essayer
de cette technique en forçant un peu
mais j'ai peur de casser le casse tête
c'est pas le but j'ai envie d'explorer
cette piste de ouf
oh
là là ça passe là haut ça passe
je suis un génie vraiment je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la méthode légale pour
finaliser ce casse tête mais du coup là
j'ai une boucle qui rentrait par là
alors à temps alors c'est maintenant il
faut essayer de faire le tour dans le
bon sens du coup si je le fais dans ce
sens là
non ça n'a pas l'air de marcher je
défais ce que je veux le faire dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
ah oui non c'est plus logique dans le
sens inverse
le défaire entièrement aux [ __ ] non
hein j'ai rajouté un tour non c'est pas
vrai j'ai mis un tour c'était c'était
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
qu'il a il fallait que je le fasse
obtint un an faut que je fasse à deux
fois l'agefi dans le sens inverse
fallait faire dans le sens des jeux le
sens maintenant sa force j'ai faim j'ai
fait un noeud en plus dans le truck of
[ __ ] j'ai le seul
je suis un génie
[Musique]
la la la la qu'est la paix s'il a bien
su bien du super le casse-tête génial
en fait là par le trou je vois qu'il y
en a un qui est enroulé tout du long
vaches j'arrive même plus à tourner ça
mais non
j'ai envie de tout arrêter là vous me
verrez rarement vu perdre complètement
même motivation sur un casse tête d'al
ala vous le voyez
comme je vous le disais au début de la
vidéo cette vidéo d'aujourd'hui est
sponsorisé par nos rvm nord vpn qui vous
permet par exemple d'élargir votre
contenu disponible que ce soit sur la
télévision en streaming ou en jeu vidéo
même mais la base de normes et pnc que
ça sert à quoi ça sert à la sécurité que
vous soyez sur des wifi public dans un
bar à la bibliothèque ou même en voyage
n'aurait pn vous protège c'est l'intérêt
premier mais vous permet aussi de
contourner les restrictions comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure par exemple
en profitant de contenu étranger depuis
la france ou en profitant de contenus
français qui n'est pas disponible parce
que vous êtes allés à l'étranger ça
marche dans les deux sens bref si vous
êtes en recherche d'un vpn ampli cas
parce que si vous cherchez pas non mais
ce qu'il faisait à rechercher un et bien
ça c'est le top vous avez un lien dans
la description je vous l'expliquais tout
à l'heure en mettant mon code fabien
olicard et en passant par ce lien ça
vous permet d'avoir une énorme réduction
sur un abonnement de deux ans un art bpn
et ça vous permet de recevoir également
un cadeau bonus et en plus de ça ça
c'est le truc que je préfère moi chez
eux c'est que vous avez un service
client en français qui est dispo 24 24 7
jours sur 7 et une garantie
remboursement de 30 jours vous pouvez
essayer nord bpn sans risque du coup et
attention essayer c'est l'adopter ça
fait dix lots dont je viens de me faire
matrix et par le casse tête et j'ai
tricks et un truc j'ai passé le truc
part au dessus pour récupérer le truc
dubaele retirer et à voir le truc en
vrai c'était une bonne idée donc
maintenant j'ai une corde qui fait le
tour de la kz puis le tour de lax etc et
là ce qui veut dire que j'ai deux fois
la difficulté du casse-tête d'origine ce
qui veut dire que j'ai pu assez de mou
pour essayer de ma petite technique qui
avait vraiment bien marché que les
styles et ce qui veut dire que je la
gelée bien dans le on peut le dire non
on peut al alaouiya ce
has a fait des bips c'était un mot de
trois lettres la fin c'était un peu
comme bull et le début c'était un peu
comme castor je sais pas comment je vais
le faire hein là je sais plus si
techniquement il est raisonnable
peut-être qu'il faut que j'en rachète un
pour ce que tu peux faire le lot si tu
as le temps et que tu à l'envi sans me
donner d'indicé tu peux regarder une
vidéo de solutions de base et me dire
juste il j'y vais pour rien ou pas
lupi box de l'enfer c'est encore moi je
fais ça là pour essayer de faire ce que
j'ai fait à l'heure mon système du
crochet mais mon but n'est plus de
résoudre le casse-tête mon but est de le
remettre dans son état d'origine serait
ce le casse-tête qui viendra à bout du
olic a prévenu loïc parce que ça fait
une heure que nous alors j'en appelle à
la pince à épiler j'utilise une pincée
pied je serais pas fier de moi mais au
moins on pourra peut-être je suis même
pas sûr peut-être aller où
après avoir beaucoup galéré je vous le
dis j'ai remis le casse-tête dans sa
position de base comment en refaisant l'
inverse de ce que j'avais fait comment
ai-je pu le faire en moins de huit jours
j'ai attrapé le fil avec le tournevis et
mais alors attendez attendez avant
d'hurler dans les commentaires même
comme ça j'ai galéré si vous allez voir
la version non montée vous allez voir
que
de ouf entre temps loïc et vous dit me
voir j'ai expliqué ce que je faisais et
il m'a dit ah oui c'est marrant parce
que j'ai regardé la solution sur
internet mois sur notre vidéo c'est pas
comme toi qu'ils font il m'a laissé avec
ça sur coup pareil ça se voit dans la
vidéo non montée écoutez très bien j'ai
envie de vous dire prenons cette corde
attachons là-haut passons la tête dedans
et mourut donc je reprends au début je
reprends je reprends je vais faire un
petit pipi je te laisse la version non
montées à disposition j'étais sur une
trottinette
eh bien non c'est ce que quand il était
au dessus ça me révolte tourner en
mouron voilà il faut que le vrille au
départ que je fasse une petite grille
comme ça
j'arrive pas à visualiser l'amateur
oui je sais que j'ai rendez vous alors
elle paraît rien cette boîte 1 mais
alors elle est relou samama
donc là je vais essayer ce coup ci comme
tout à l'heure de de récupérer en fait
cette corde par ce côté là or j'ai
réussi
ok donc là là je les passais la halle à
aller passer la jupe un ouf ça c'est le
côté gauche ça c'est le côté droit
bonjour donc là si je suis là et que je
fais un tour entier si jean mimi et que
je tourne celui là non je ne peux pas le
tourner là je suis en train de faire
n'importe quoi je crois j'avais même
plus à tourner ça bloque dedans ça veut
dire qu'actuellement dedans et ça ça va
faire claque et ça marche pas à ma moi
je comprends plus rien c'est impossible
que ça marche pas les deux sont bien du
même côté et elle me casse la t27 boîte
mais comment c'est possible ça sert aux
mines ou alors à temps et quelques uns
il y avait touché à ce casse tête avant
qu'on le fasse
et un jury de le casser en huit genres
il le jetait pas une mocheté avec mais
là il tient comment on a du coup un
[ __ ] je ne comprends d'un truc feront
peut-être cette chose peut m'aider en
gros depuis le départ je croyais que la
corde elle était tenue par cet axe là en
gros qu'elle tournait autour de cet axe
en fait pas du tout la corde elle est là
elle est tenue sur le pico sur ce pico
et quand je le lève c'est fait de
manière assez maligne pour que même en
levant le pico l'accord n'est pas assez
d'espacé en fait pour passer et donc
quand je lève le pico il se lève pas
assez pour que la corde passe il ya pas
assez d espace en fait pour qu elle pour
qu'elle soit libérée mais en vrai ça
explique pourquoi j'ai raté tant de fois
donc déjà il faut que je la ramène dans
sa position
[Musique]
on a l'impression que la corde elle fait
le tour en fait elle fait le tort que de
ce pico
tu savais
donc là si je tourne par là bas
je rabat en entier je le mets en face là
maintenant là j'ai toute ma corde est
attaché au pico dans ce sens là on a
presque la situation de départ si le
pico était là-bas quoi tu vois en face
c'est trop bizarre et si je lève le pico
évidemment il ya pas assez d espace pour
sa tasse par en dessous et mère je
commence à voir extrêmement mal au pouce
et ça s'entend de ma voix à bagré si
légèrement abati voilà enfin sa percée
il fallait lever plus tu vois que je
levais comme importe tout à l'heure ab
oui bon ben voilà voilà voilà voilà ce
qu'il y avait dans ce qui casse tête bon
par contre un quatrième n'est pas
résolue tant qu'il n'a pas été revendus
non il faut je leur mette non mais là il
faut que je le passe sous le pic ou
alors que picot déjà j'avais même pu
admettre en dessous là
la boîte est remise
non bon alors déjà merci à vous qui avez
regardé cette vidéo dans son entièreté
si vous vous êtes sur la chaîne
principale sachez qu'il ya la version
sans aucun montage aucune coupe sur la
chaîne secondaire vous avez le lien dans
la description et vous pouvez y aller
merci également aux normes epn d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo vous avez le lien
vers nord des peines dans la description
et avec mon coach fabien olicard vous
avez une grosse réduction sur les deux
ans d'abonnement est aussi un cadeau
bonus en plus de ça tout est expliqué
moi je vous remercie de suivre les
aventures des casse têtes en approche
les deux millions d'abonnés peut-être
cette année ça ça dépendra de vous ici
je vous mets deux autres vidéos c'est
une un casse tête que m'a fabriqué un
labo ethnik qui s'appelle fg baker et ça
c'était une l'aller d-box de constantin
aussi qui était une excellente boîte et
je vous donne rendez-vous lundi prochain
pour la prochaine vidéo puisse te lis
car des cuisines sur la chaîne vous
n'êtes pas prêts à très bientôt de
chalon